quand j'aurai terminé sert phase nous
auront parcouru plus de 2000 km autour
du centre de notre galaxie
c'est fait ils sont bougés de laon des
jeux d'hier on se trouve sur une planète
qui tourne sur elle même
autour d'une étoile qui elle-même tourne
autour du centre de la voie lactée
etc etc c'est vertigineux
quand on y pense vraiment en général ya
deux cas de figure soit on ressent de la
fascination et de l'excitation
soit on ressent de la peur et de
l'angoissé mais dans les deux cas c'est
humain il ya une émotion qui nous
envahissent là en l'occurrence elle est
liée à notre mouvement autour du centre
galactique
c'est parce que nous sommes nus que nous
sommes émus je suis candidate
un projet qui s'appelle marc swan et qui
envisage sérieusement d'établir une base
humaine permanente sur la planète mars
et la question qu'on pose le plus
souvent c'est pourquoi effectivement
pourquoi pourquoi vouloir partir
s'installer sur une planète qui se
trouve à plusieurs dizaines voire
centaines de millions de kilomètres
d'ici où on ne trouve pas d'eau à l'état
liquide où il fait moins 63 degrés en
moyenne et où l'atmosphère est composé à
95% de co2 pourquoi alors je donne
toujours tout un tas de réponse très
rationnels comme la volonté d'y faire
des expériences scientifiques
la curiosité de savoir si l'être humain
est capable de s'adapter à un
environnement aussi hostile l'envi de
réaliser un rêve de petite fille ou de
poser la première pierre à une
éventuelle chance de survie de
l'humanité en tant qu'espèce mais tout
ça enfin ça reste vrai ça reste vrai
mais c'est presque secondaire sauf que
la raison première est irrationnelle et
que j'ai dû j'ai du mal à me mettre des
mots dessus il s'agit d'un ressenti
tellement puissant que le langage ne
peut rien pour rendre compte de ce que
je ressens alors souvent je dis que j'ai
j'en ai simplement envie mais pourquoi
j'ai cette envie pourquoi nous avons
tous ici des envies des pulsions des
forces qui nous pousse à accomplir des
choses qui nous attire dans des
directions très précises
pourquoi et ça peut prendre ça peut
prendre n'importe quelle forme alors moi
ça prend la forme de ma passion pour les
sciences de l'univers et pour
l'exploration spatiale
mais ça peut être n'importe quoi d'autre
ça peut être une vocation ça peut être
un désir d'enfant ça peut être une
passion pourquoi on se démène pour quoi
on se bouge pour accomplir tout ça on
cherche à être ému je crois m'être un
bébé au monde le regarde et s'épanouir
s'éveiller grandir ça doit être
absolument bouleversant réussir à faire
le métier dont on rêvait lorsqu'on était
enfant tenir son diplôme entre ses mains
se lever chaque matin le coeur battant à
l'idée de la journée qui nous attend
c'est un truc de dingue ça donnait une
passion essayer d'en faire le tour se
l'approprier la partager avec d'autres
passionnés ou la transmettre à ceux qui
ne le sont pas encore c'est des moments
incroyables on aspire tous à vivre ça
qui n'a jamais rêvé le temps d'une
journée de vivre la vie d'une star de
cinéma ou de la musique d'un joueur de
football d'une astronaute ou d'un grand
de ce monde
on l'a tous plus ou moins fantasmée
parce qu'on se demande ce que ça fait on
se demande ce que peut bien ressentir
cette personne ça fait quoi
d'interpréter la princesse leia
ça fait quoi de marquer un but en coupe
du monde alors que c'est déjà un truc de
malade depuis son canapé
ça fait quoi de marché sur la lune
on cherche sans arrêt à être ému on vit
pour trouver des émotions qui nous
transporte c'est parce que nous sommes
émus que nous sommes mus je veux voyager
vers mars
parce que je veux savoir ce que ça fait
de fouler le sol d'un autre monde mais
pas seulement
je suis né à vitry le françois j'ai
grandi à châlons-en-champagne et lors
d'une journée tout à fait banale de ma
vie d'adolescente de 16 ans on m'a
annoncé qu'une tumeur avait élu domicile
entre mon oeil droit et mon cerveau
alors c'est elle s'était installée elle
grossissait prenait sa place tranquille
où elle a cru que mon nerf optique était
un hamac et surtout elle ne comptait pas
du tout payer de loyer alors les
médecins il n'était pas d'accord ils
m'ont dit écoute écoute à avoir une
araignée au plafond bomba passe encore
enfin un oursin dans le salon non non
non fall expulsé alors c'était pas sans
risque je ne vous le cache pas mais il
fallait faire quelque chose alors je
suis venu à reims pour le gros oeuvre
les médecins sont passés par le toit ils
ont mis six heures à la déloger la sale
bête s'accrochait mais ils ont été cool
quand même ils ont laissé l'endroit
aussi propre qu'il l'avait trouvé en
arrivant à un détail près ils ont oublié
le volet roulant à droite et les jamais
remonté je suis resté borgne pendant six
mois
alors j'ai commencé par perdre la vision
en trois dimensions
c'est compliqué à se déplacer quand on a
pas de notion de relief ou de distance
et les couleurs se sont petit à petit
estompée et puis un jour j'ai réussi à
soulever ma paupière et là j'ai vu le
monde comme jamais je ne l'avais vu
auparavant et s'est elle même pourtant
ce qui était même passé la ville c'était
le ciel c'était les arbres c'était les
fleurs mais des fleurs partout parce
qu'on était au mois de juin mais il
avait rien à voir ce monde je les
regardais pour la première fois et je l'
ai vu et il y avait des couleurs partout
elle brillait
et ces formes qui lui donnait du corps
c'était c'était c'était hallucinant ce
que je ressentais physiquement les trois
dimensions des espaces et je me suis
sentie vivre à ce moment là grâce est
grâce à ce toutes ces émotions qui
m'avait envahi et ce jour là je me suis
juré de tout faire pour m'émerveiller
chaque jour de la beauté du monde et de
ce qui m'entoure je suis né à vitry j'ai
grandi à chalon et je suis devant vous
ici aujourd'hui pour vous dire que je
fais tout pour aller fouler le sol d'un
autre monde pour aller le voir de mes
propres yeux pour le pour l'explorer
pour le vivre avec tous mes sens et je
sais pas si j'y arriverais mais au fond
peu importe parce que je me démène pour
y arriver
et parce que je vous le dis ici dans la
ville où je ne suis pas morte il ya des
étapes clés la navy alors évidemment il
ya la naissance
et puis après ce sont les premiers pas
qui sont symboliques c'est vrai en
général on fait pas grand cas du premier
repas solide comprend après des mois de
biberons ou de la première nuit complète
qu'on passe enfin quoique ça ça dépend
peut-être des bébés je sais pas dans
tous les cas tous les parents se
souviennent des premiers pas de leur
enfant et c'est sûrement parce que c'est
la première étape vers l'autonomie quand
on lâche pour la première fois la main
de ses parents on leur dit bah ça y est
je peux marcher tout seul maintenant je
peux aller explorer le monde sans vous
et on y va on explore alors mon
l'exploration commence quand même avant
par la bouche d'abord et ensuite à
quatre pattes à toucher à tout et à
mettre les doigts dans tous les trous
qui passe mais quand on marche on va
plus loin et surtout quand on se lève le
regard porte plus loin et
et finalement un enfant sait rien
d'autre qu'un explorateur est un
scientifique
il expérimente tout le temps il est dans
un parc par exemple trouver un bâton par
terre il tape sur le sol c'est rigolo
bon il va taper sur la grille du parc ça
va faire du bruit est plus amusant donc
il va recommencer
et au final il va choisir le support et
le bâton qui font le plus de bruit à
tous les deux parce que louis est un des
sens qui nous permettent d'appréhender
le monde et c'est comme ça qu'il explore
c'est comme ça qu'ils expérimentent et
on a tous fait ça moi j'ai la chance
d'avoir une de mes toutes premières
expériences scientifiques d'archivés
dans mon album photo c'est en deux
parties c'est le jour de mon premier
anniversaire je suis donc sur ma chaise
haute avec une part de gâteau une bougie
dessus sur la première photo on me voit
porter mon doigt vers la flamme de la
bougie
c'est la deuxième photo bon je braille
finalement c'est une expérience que je
n'ai jamais renouveler mais j'en ai fait
d'autres comme tous les enfants et comme
tous les enfants j'ai grandi et on m'a
appris à rester à ma place à ne pas être
trop curieuse à être sage ce genre de
choses mais moi je voulais continuer à
explorer et je voulais éviter tout lé
monde de l'univers je lisais des livres
d'aventurés j'allais voir des films qui
m'emmenait très très loin et j'ai voyagé
dès que j'en ai eu l'occasion et il ya
autre chose qu'on fait quand on grandit
ou plutôt qu'on ne fait plus c'est à
montrer ses émotions un enfant ça rit ça
pleure ça ces merveilles tout le temps
sarsan du dégoût de la surprise je ne le
cache pas à jamais un adulte ça rit
aussi bien sûr mais pas trop fort
surtout si c'est une femme ça pleure il
faut surtout pas que ça se voit surtout
si c'est un homme ça peut être ému bien
sûr évidemment mais on le cache parce
que sinon ça peut devenir gênante mal à
l'aise mais pourquoi pourquoi on fait ça
pour quoi au fur et à mesure qu'on
grandit on refoule notre nature notre
nature d'êtres humains explorateurs mû
par l'émotion et la curiosité
pourquoi moi j'ai pas envie de devenir
ce robot passif et froid c'est pour ça
que tu m'intéresses temps aux sciences
de l'univers et à l'exploration spatiale
parce que dans ces domaines on est
émerveillé sans arrêt et on s'émeut tout
le temps à chaque fois que je suis
devant une image de
bulleuse par exemple je me sent envahie
d'un sentiment d'émerveillement infinie
et de profonde humilité
à chaque fois que je regarde un
décollages de fusées je vibre
physiquement en même temps que la fusée
qui décolle ça me fait vibrer à chaque
fois que je regarde sur internet les
images de la terre qui tourne en direct
filmée depuis les caméras de la station
spatiale internationale j'en ai les
larmes aux yeux
systématiquement je ne fais pas et j'ai
pleuré pleuré en même temps que les
scientifiques et techniciens les
ingénieurs hommes et femmes qui avaient
travaillé sur le robot curiosity quand
elle s'est posé sans problème sur mars
et j'ai recommencé la semaine dernière
quand fila et s'est posé sur la comète
on a pleuré tous ensemble on s'en cacher
pas parce qu'on était ému et c'était
bien et on était émerveillé de voir que
ce petit robot qui avait passé dix ans
dans l'espace s'était posé comme on
l'avait prévu
c'était merveilleux et c'était émouvant
et je veux jamais cessé de m'émerveiller
et de m'émouvoir et je pense qu'on a
tout ça en commun il sait ce soir parce
que vous êtes venu assister à tmx est
d'ailleurs merci d'être venus merci de
vous êtes déplacé pour venir découvrir
de nouvelles idées merci d'avoir eu
cette curiosité c'est très sain la
curiosité c'est récents de vous lasser
de vouloir savoir le plus de choses
possible c'est très sain de voir
comprendre le monde et les fun et les
phénomènes qui nous entoure c'est pas du
tout un vilain défaut
la curiosité parce que ça mène à la
connaissance et si parfois c'est
beaucoup de travail c'est vrai pour
enfin réussir à comprendre quelque chose
qui nous échappait depuis depuis très
longtemps c'est c'est tellement jouissif
d'enfin comprendre ce qui ce qui nous
échappait et c'est pour ça que des
chercheurs des scientifiques passent
parfois toute leur vie toute une
carrière sur un petit détail de leur
domaine pour arriver à cette émotion
pour arriver à ce point de sa y'est j'ai
compris ça fait quoi de toucher au but
et ben si on peut le savoir si on veut
connaître cette émotion mais faut se
mettre en mouvement il faut avancer il
faut être curieux il faut chercher à
vivre le plus d'émotions possibles et ça
peut prendre n'importe quelle forme pour
moi ça prend la forme de ma passion pour
les sciences de l'univers pour
l'exploration spatiale et pour
l'exploration marque
mais ça peut être n'importe quoi d'autre
ça dépend de chacun de vous les sciences
et l'exploration spatiale c'est mon truc
mais vous c'est quoi votre truc
qu'est ce qui vous fait vibrer qu'est-ce
qui vous émeut qu'est-ce qui vous
émerveille et quoi que ce soit dans tous
les cas albert einstein avait doublement
raison avec son équation e égal mc2 et
je vais vous le prouver
l'émotion est égal au mouvement x la
curiosité au carré